[Musique]
90% des feux sont d'origine anthropique
d'origine humaine 95% des feux en France
sont éteints alors qu'ils ont parcouru
moins de 5 hectares mais il reste 5% des
feux qui dépassent les 1000 hectares et
donc notre réflexion est partie de ce
constat et qui consiste à ce que nous
travaillons avant tout la prévention
sans négliger la réponse opérationnelle
la première des choses qui semble banal
mais qui pourtant est particulièrement
importante c'est qui est une mission
interministérielle qui se mette en place
et quand on est plus l'opposition que
l'on a rencontré sur nombre de feux les
derniers celui de 21 dans le Var ceux de
l'année dernière sur les Landes où on
est on a l'opposition entre le code
forestier et le code de l'environnement
on oblige les propriétaires d'habitat
dans des endroits très risqués en termes
de feux de forêt à débroussailler 50
mètres avec certaines normes les arbres
pas plus de 3 mètres etc autour de leur
habitat ça permet de protéger non
seulement l'habitat mais ça permet aussi
de protéger les habitants dont on peut
demander à ce qu'il soit confiné à
l'intérieur pourquoi parce qu'on n'a pas
les moyens de mettre un camion de
pompiers et une équipe derrière chaque
habitat dans un habitat diffus et on
sait que quand les Old sont très bien
faites c'est une protection quasiment
assurée à 100 et puis une deuxième
partie sur cette loi c'est la partie
agricole parce qu'on s'aperçoit que non
seulement les feux de forêt se
développent de plus en plus mais
également les feux de végétation et
notamment au moment de la récolte c'est
ces mêmes feux de végétaux qui peuvent
provoquer des feux de forêt beaucoup
plus grands donc il faut qu'on incite
qu'on pousse à modifier quelque peu les
pratiques agricoles faut pas oublier que
la forêt c'est 17 millions d'HECT
ares dont tous les acteurs à l'ONF aussi
pour la propriété forestière que tout
secteur soit plus mobilisé plus présent
en forêt pour mieux détecter donc voilà
une prise de conscience une de culture
du risque plus de gens en forêt et puis
après aussi une meilleure connaissance
et c'est pour ça que nous avons aussi
besoin d'un recherche pour nous aider à
savoir quels sont le type d'essence
comment voilà comment on doit s'adapter
parce qu'on a on ne connaît pas tout en
matière de sciences de la nature on a
besoin de la recherche de l'innovation
après derrière il y a le volet pour les
pompiers il n'est pas normal que comme
l'armée il puisse pas bénéficier d'une
exonération sur les carburants de la
même façon les exonérer de malus sur les
véhicules
pour battre le feu la réponse est unique
c'est la solidarité nationale qui doit
faire face à ce problème qui concerne
l'ensemble du territoire il y a quelques
années nous parlions de la saison des
feux de forêts du mois de juillet du
mois d'août aujourd'hui on le voit les
premiers feux de forêt démarre en
février
et pour certains se termine en octobre
ou novembre et donc il faut encore une
fois avoir une approche globale
[Musique]